the way I come at it is this there are
tests for truth and there are objects of
those tests and I say it's this there
are really four questions of life David
origin meaning morality and destiny that
forms our worldview where did I come
from what his life actually mean how do
I differentiate good and evil what
happens to human being when he or she
dies and therefore you put the two tests
of truth correspondence and coherence on
my answers corresponding to reality
so you mentioned judeo-christian values
and since we've talked about Shapiro and
Dennis Prager who come at this obviously
from a Jewish perspective and you can
agree to disagree on whatever those
those outside issues are but when you
when you walk away from a conversation
with someone like the two of them or
someone from a different from not a
Protestant outlook on life etc do you
feel that they're missing something that
is a invaluable point to your worldview
well if truth by definition is exclusive
and if one disagrees with the other
there is still their necessity of the
truth you know
Prager I thought had a wonderful answer
when we were talking and he is very
respectful to me as I am of him and
Prager looked at me and said when
Messiah comes I will have only one
question for him have you been here
before and you know I think that is that
tells me how the man is thinking but let
me give you another illustration there's
a very great Hebrew scholar in Jerusalem
I was writing a book on comparative
worldviews and I spent some more than
brilliant time I say Sharon he is
written more on the inscriptions in the
Middle East than anybody else multiple
volumes if I'm not mistaken 20 or 30
volumes and he looked at me on one point
and he said this he said mr. Zakaria you
and I may have our differences but we
have learned one very essential thing in
common I said what is that sir he said
our goal in life is to have communion
with God I said I agree with you and
then he went on to say something
fascinating about how he differed from
other religious world views on that
Manor but not with the Christian well
view and that's why I think the
judeo-christian worldview and Ben
Shapiro said to me you know what was
missing in the old US Mint what was
wrong I said no it was not wrong it was
the gradual unfolding of that
relationship with God that we were
offered and that the grace that is given
to you and me right from the beginning
has hints of this and the mirror of the
law told me my face was dirty but the
mirror couldn't clean my face I had to
go to the faucet to find that cleansing
I said so it's a complimentary Ness and
a completion but to get to the heart of
your question yes I would go back and
say you know there's one link here that
is not as strong he may think the same
of me yeah so the way I come at it is
this there are tests for truth and there
are objects of those tests and I say
it's this there are really four
questions of life David origin meaning
morality and destiny that forms our
worldview where did I come from what his
life actually mean how do I
differentiate good and evil what happens
to human being when he or she dies and
therefore you put the two tests of truth
correspondence and coherence on my
answers corresponding to reality when my
answers are put together
is there a coherence to them and to me
in that judeo-christian worldview it
meets the do test of coherence and
correspondence with the four questions
of life so then from there without
getting too lost in the politics of the
day when I watch these debates or just
sort of anything that's happening
politically I always am thinking well
why would I want these people to have
any power over my life they don't seem
to be addressing anything that that
really matters right they're not gonna
really have an honest you know they'll
maybe ask them a quick question on faith
and they give you some some glib answer
or something like that but I think part
of the issue right now is that they feel
politicians feel they can solve all of
man's problems but you would basically
argue these are not even for a man to
solve in the first place or something
like how I think politics is a necessary
evil in our time but a good politician
is the most difficult job
our time and there are good people out
there I've met them I know them and they
are the ones who grieve most as to what
has happened somebody told me and from
the State Department I've been here 30
years I've never seen the mood so toxic
as it is now we need it we need these
structures but I think we need examples
to model it not just to speak it and
most of the time as I said I'm very
troubled about what's happening globally
I see it I see two of the major a
theistic religions of the atheistic
countries of the world demagogues in
charge of the they're not giving their
people the freedom to believe or to
disbelieve while they are increasing
their footprint all over America what's
the thing you talk about China and
Russia and Russia yeah and what are we
doing out here we are fighting each
other you know there's an old adage how
horses fight and how donkeys fight when
horses fight they face each other form a
circle and the attacker comes and they
kick against the attacker but donkeys
fight they form a circle with their
backs to each other and face the
attacker and what do they do end up
kicking each other to death and so
that's the way we are doing politics not
all by the way there are good
politicians there but throwing the oil
into the flames one after another think
of what the last two years have been
spent by politician doing peripheral
stuff while we are fiddling while Rome
is burning here I am talking to you Los
Angeles it grieved me this morning to be
sitting having my breakfast in a
restaurant of the bowl of cereal and
looking at the number of homeless
walking by it just crushed me you know
what has brought all this about let's
sit down and find a solution to these
think of the number of people dying
because of the opioid crisis think of
our young people who are battling the
destruction and the family and the home
and all of this we're not addressing any
of those things
instead what were your tax returns or it
looks like we are only only following
the money trail we are not following the
trail of conscience and cultural
well-being
well we seem to be following the shiny
object that's ever moving and it
provokes those who are with you on your
side yeah I've got a punch that guy in
the face really and then what my
professor used to say some people are
better at smaller smelling rotten eggs
than laying good ones and that's really
what we're doing to go back I think what
we need is a test of character not
uniform in our beliefs but a character
that will hold integrity as a primary
method of discourse if you lose that you
lose the discourse doesn't it seem
though that that would be almost
impossible right now to break through
the ether which is maybe why you said
you think it's gonna get worse before
it's gonna get better
and I think some great tragedy will hit
us and then we will awaken is that it I
mean that I've said that once or twice
and I don't like thinking it I mean you
don't want to think that that something
horrific would have to happen so that it
would be the only way we could reset
which of course nobody wants to happen
and yet we find ourselves in this weird
thing it's like what else what else
would do it
it's a good question and I know and a
worthy question you know I don't think
there's a simplistic answer but I just
go with people whom I know in my own
heart if everything is going well okay
and then you start worrying about your
car you know that you bought a lemon and
it's not running properly but all of a
sudden you find out one of your children
or grandchildren has just been hit in a
car wreck
and their body is shattered it changes
everything of importance right then and
I know people to whom it's happened they
can be arguing and all of a sudden they
find out they've got cancer or the
pancreas or something and the whole
demeanor of life changes so that's the
way sometimes our attention is brought
to what really matters I'm hoping what
happens individually and relationally
with our friends it it seems to be an
intimation of how we ultimately wake up
to what's happening think of the nuclear
threat today who in their right mind
would want to see a nuclear war you know
we even just seen pictures of Hiroshima
Masaki and you say they are hell on
earth but we've got regimes but people
who are willing to do things like that
so is it going to take some awful
cataclysmic event for us to say stop
everything has to stop we have to sit
down and talk I don't know the only
other possibility David is this and that
as a man who loves Christ and loves the
spiritual world as reality some great
revival breaks out somewhere and hearts
get changed and we find a sympathy
towards things that really matter not
towards perfil issues that's always a
possibility it's happened in history a
dramatic change of heart of an
individual I see it happening in prisons
I see it happening in arenas and if that
happens on a massive scale which is what
a Christian would call a revival then
that would be the only hope if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about spirituality instead
of non-stop yelling check out our
spirituality playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out our full episode
playlist there all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell